in this video argo in to continue our
project extremely two
impotent concepts in the planning park
corporation and drove in that sense in the
previous video
we have already such the forward
staff model structure first is
if you have some to actually work its core
then we  can further transvorm de like
its course in 2 pro bally types of de
max function and family pack comparing the
probability smith labels diy how to
encode
week en Katholieke de percent i feel as
well how i once wrestled a relationship formation
buck know how to find model
and updated on record this process pack
publication of origin there is no error
update mode with you seen this pack pro
detail information
to answer this question level i got the
relationship between the last function and
the the motor couple myths of simplicité
les only' concealer  troop few meters
tabje one and the bluetooth here we go
catholic glass for each points on this
part and finally glass function in three
die plat
de service ch  ip is tip en dan de la
fonction using
de mill you're using en de tab of
problems you work you have in this
function plat
something horny a sangha it all
agreed at mee kim predictions for the
caribbean karmic setting and more
importantly
it tellson's  wooden on your maister
parameter set the chicken and point to be more
specific
which direction you should go to decrease
a lastpost quickly with help of the
single barrel linda leather case in
point for this can of complete ideal
as function here is a ladder loco
minimum in this  plan how the most beautiful
goal and a few things from the start
point
how to find to global minimum is
another I pulled it not going to tap
tiep today
that he hit the wall of fame and coins
and how to optimize parameters and
integrity
known further  simplified is problem
only the tab your when mieters en kip the
bluetooth fixed
knives michiel bicker right up date
function for that your one s the lenny you
know thai demolition of the counterpoi  nt
en en demolition can be obtained with de
patient er effective op de la foce
ok je free to the three people i work
on enterprise decade of de function
after some intrigue
boldero process three tens cents
we gave love peace is a red devil
local cold
20  rue des pièces for a three cylinder
training process
we hid in the motor boat was a
nice find you for the weekend acolytes
de la fonction white men outputs and
labels de la fonction using is the crash
entropy
family angle and peppa pig eat the loose and
optimal  per meter white green day cent
this is an introduction as feedback
propagation green decent concept and in
the knox the video in which the talk about
how to develop our trip to mobile to
forget to subscribe to our a the
notification bar street und